tailwind a massive collection of tiny
css utility classes for quickly and
consistently building good-looking
websites css is hard design is also hard
but naming your css classes in a sane
way is virtually impossible frameworks
like bootstrap and material address this
challenge by creating styles for high
level components things like buttons
drop downs and forms tailwind takes a
more functional approach by providing
you with utility classes that can be
composed together to build components
like this instead of using the card
class like you might in bootstrap you
combine utility classes like flex to
make it a flexbox p to give it padding m
for margin and hundreds of others to
control things like color shadows and so
on in addition every utility can be
applied conditionally you have variants
like small medium and large for
responsive designs along with a bunch of
pseudo-selectors like hover and focus to
handle state changes or dark to render
different colors when dark mode is
enabled this approach gives you a lot
more freedom over your creativity
compared to other css frameworks while
at the same time following the rules of
a design system that you don't get with
plain css it lives in the sweet spot
between convention and configuration
however it does produce some ugly ass
html you've got tons of hard to read
duplicated class names here as your ui
grows in complexity code duplication is
inevitable but you can avoid it by
creating reusable components with your
favorite javascript framework or by
using the apply directive in css to take
tailwind classes and compose them into a
single concise class name another
concern you may have is performance
because tailwind weighs in at over 3 500
kilobytes but when you go to build for
production it will automatically purge
any unused utility from the final bundle
resulting in minimal dead code and thus
faster page loads but who has time to
learn and memorize all these different
utility classes where tailwind really
shines is with its tooling you don't
need to memorize much because vs code
will auto-complete every tailwind class
if you're not sure what it does just
hover over it and it will show you the
equivalent code in plain css and if
you're not happy with what it does you
can easily customize everything from the
color palette to the spacing to build
your own unique design system this has
been tailwind css in 100 seconds make
sure to like and subscribe if you want
to see more short videos like this and
if we hit 10 000 likes i'll make a full
tailwind tutorial thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one